[Music]
here's a very simplified model of an
atom the nucleus at the center of the
atom is where the protons and neutrons
live but they're kinda boring because
for the most part they just sit there
the real star of the show is the
electron the electron gets to do all the
interesting stuff like move around Jump
Around bind with other atoms these
dashed lines represent the different
energy levels the electron can have
while in the atom we like representing
these energy levels with an energy level
diagram the energy level diagram gives
us a way to show what energy the
electron has without having to draw an
atom with a bunch of circles all the
time let's say our pretend atom has
electron energy levels of zero EV for Ev
6ev and 7 EV note that moving left or
right on an energy level diagram doesn't
actually represent anything meaningful
so technically there is no x-axis on an
energy level diagram but we draw it
there anyway because it makes it look
nice all that matters is what energy
level or wrong on the ladder the
electron is at note that the electron
for our hypothetical atom here can only
exist with zero EV four six or seven EV
the electron just cannot exist between
energy levels it's always got to be
right on one of the energy levels
okay so let's say our electron starts
off on the Zero EV energy level it's
good to note that the lowest energy
level an electron can have in an atom is
called the ground state so how could our
electron get from the ground state to
any of the higher energy levels well for
the electron to get to a higher energy
level we've got to give the electron
more energy and we know how to give an
electron more energy you just shoot
light at it if a photon of the right
energy can strike an electron the
electron will absorb all the photons
energy and jump to a higher energy level
the electron in this ground state needs
four EV to jump to the next energy level
that means if a photon that had an
energy of 4ev came in and struck the
electron the electron would absorb the
energy of the photon causing the photon
to disappear and that electron would
jump up to the next energy level we call
the first energy level after the ground
state the first excited state once the
electron runs at the higher energy level
it won't stay there long electrons if
given the chance will fall towards the
lowest energy level they can so our
electron will fall back down to the
ground state and give up for Ev of
energy the way an electron can give up
energy is by emitting a photon so after
falling back down to the ground state
this electron would emit a four EV
Photon electrons don't have to just jump
one energy level at a time though if the
electron in our ground state were to
absorb a 6ev photon the electron can
jump all the way up to the 6ev energy
level now that the electrons at a higher
energy level it's gonna try to fall back
down but there's a couple ways it could
fall back down in this case the electron
could fall down to the ground state all
in one shot giving up a 6ev photon in
the process but since the electron
started at the 6ev energy level it could
have also Fallen first to the four EV
energy level people emitting a 2ev
photon in the process it's a 2ev photon
because the electron dropped two
electron volts in energy and now that
the electrons at the four EV energy
level it'll fall back down to the ground
state emitting a four EV Photon in the
process so electrons will sometimes drop
multiple energy levels at a time and
sometimes they'll choose to take
individual steps but regardless the
energy of the photon is always equal to
the difference in electron energy levels
what if our electrons in the ground
state and we send a five EV Photon at it
if the electron were to absorb all of
the energy of the five EV Photon it
would now have five electron volts but
that's not an allowed energy level so
the electron can't absorb this Photon
and the photon will pass straight
through the atom keep in mind the
electron in the atom has to absorb all
of the photons energy or none of it it
can't just absorb part of it alright so
now we can figure out every possible
Photon this atom could absorb if the
electrons in the ground state it could
absorb a four EV Photon or a 6ev photon
or a 7ev photon if the electrons at the
second energy level also called the
first excited state the electron could
absorb a two EV Photon or a three EV
Photon and if the electron were at the
third energy level or the second excited
state the electron could absorb a one EV
Photon those are the only photons that
this atom will be seen to absorb
2.5 EV photons will pass straight
through five EV photons will pass
straight through 6.3 EV photons will
pass straight through what this means is
that if you were to shine light that
consisted of all possible wavelengths
through a gas that was composed of our
pretend atoms all the wavelengths would
not make it through some of the
wavelengths would get absorbed then
scattered away in random directions this
would manifest itself as dark lines in
the Spectrum missing wavelengths or
missing energy levels that correspond to
the energies of photons that our
electron can absorb this is like a
fingerprint for an atom and it's called
that atom's absorption Spectrum if you
were to ever see this progression of
dark lines in these exact positions you
would know that the gas you were looking
at was composed at least partly of our
hypothetical atom this also allows
astronomers to determine what stuff in
our universe is made out of even though
we can't get get close enough to collect
a sample all we have to do is collect
light from a distant star or Quasar that
shines through the stuff we're
interested in then just determine which
wavelengths or energies got taken out
the details are a little messier than
that but this provides astronomers with
maybe the most important tool at their
disposal now the absorption Spectrum are
all of the wavelengths or energies that
an atom will absorb from light that
passes through it you could also ask
about the emission spectrum the emission
spectrum or all of the wavelengths or
energies that an atom will emit due to
electrons falling down in energy levels
you could go through all the
possibilities of an electron falling
down again but you'd realize you're
going to get the exact same energies for
the mission spectrum that you got for
the absorption Spectrum so instead of
letting light pass through a gas
composed of your hypothetical atoms
let's say you made a container that had
the gas of your hypothetical atoms and
you ran an electric current through it X
citing those electrons to higher energy
levels and letting them fall back down
to lower energy levels this is what
happens in neon lights or if you're in
science class it's what happens in gas
discharge tubes so for the emission
spectrum instead of seeing the whole
electromagnetic spectrum with a few
lines missing you're going to only see a
handful of lines that correspond to the
energies of those photons that that atom
will emit